there's why have one more if you guys
want to do a more leading one yeah in
the past I've had trouble staying
monogamous in relationships and I'm
scared that I could one day [ __ ] up my
future family in a relationship with
someone I truly love by cheating I
always go into a relationship thinking
that I would never do something like
that but alcohol sex addiction hormones
emotions or whatever else it could have
been has caused me to mess up in the
past my mother had one to two affairs
and I think it may have severely messed
with my head and understanding of
relationships cheating does lead me to a
monstrous shame guilt self-hatred
suicidal thoughts bah-bah-bah
can you guys touch and how you stay
monogamous I meant to say which makes me
wonder okay can you guys touch on how
how you stay monogamous why you think
people cheat and possibly share your
experiences is there any retribution for
past cheaters how many people do you
have to sleep with before you're ready
to settle down B love B was my parents
were monogamous and their old Korean
people and they just never cheated and
and so I just I don't know what it is I
just have never done it you've never
cheated anyone in your life I have done
this I have gone to a strip club and
gotten a lap dance and came through my
jeans without my dick out I don't think
that counts yeah that's what I'm saying
that's the most I've done and even when
I did that it was like I was on the
board of relapse like I was sober then
you know I mean like I had to talk to a
thousand people so I just I've never
done it but at the same time I don't
know if I'd be devastated if somebody
cheated on me Wow that she really would
not be devastated I mean it would be
like why'd you do that like we have a
monogamous thing I think that monogamy
is just a decision to people make I
don't think it
like how all a relationship should be I
know people who are in open marriages
who've been together you know I don't
know anybody sent an open marriage
oh it never lasts forever never I don't
know anyone that's last aside from Will
Smith and Jada Pinkett and I don't know
how do you think there's no way well I
lived with two men for years for what
four guys know okay guys they're gonna
choose for one met her right better she
was living with two not guys that she
was seeing both of them at the same time
yeah but that was also to make sure yes
they were roommates all of them they
weren't particularly close they kind of
just tolerated each had not tolerated
they were friends maybe travel together
they don't do did never did one another
no no no I'll do my ghetto yeah yes but
it was exhausting for me and I will
never do that again
because to care about the emotions of
two people was I thought resulting Wow I
get this freedom and it you it's not
freedom in fact it's a bigger ball chain
you have to keep up with the line yeah
yeah yeah there were two great people
but it was way more exhausting than I
was ready for and no I can't I don't
have the energy to even [ __ ] brush my
hair are you seeing anybody no no I got
rid of my third ex-fiance who was it a
comic or no no this is a gonna sound
real weird
it was dices ex-wife's uncle but they
were together when we were dating
because dice got divorced again a year
ago but I was dating her uncle oh wow
real white trash Wow but he was awesome
he's awesome he's great we see young
that the last party I don't know
everybody good-looking no oh her yeah
yeah she was gorgeous how long will hold
us here how old when I saw the photos it
was like [ __ ] that's how old she was
when they got married yeah they were
together for eight years Wow see how
good your math is there
three there you go I'm looking at you
for help no but yeah so her uncle and I
went out but we're still friendly he
just it's just didn't worry he was
always jealous always thought I was
cheating because he was a cheat his
whole life and has trust issues I almost
threw him off a boat we were on a cruise
I was working the Kid Rock cruise yeah I
was like I'm just gonna kill him like
we're both ghetto like that we have no
problem burying someone yeah no problem
would never kill them you have no idea
what I would do but I literally was
thinking oh this is easy just tip him
over
yeah so and I always tell him about it
and he loud because it's just that's how
angry I was that if if I was talking to
somebody he'd be like why'd you hug that
guy twice and I'm like I can't do this
yeah you can't do it giant dick but I'm
going yeah so what do you guys what
advice do you have to offer to the guy
who wants to keep his dick monogamy is
not real I mean if you don't find the
person you love then do you think that
it's easy to to stay faithful if you
absolutely love somebody yes I think so
do you think that it's human in its
inner human nature to stay with one
person that's a very broad philosophical
question that I I'm not really willing
to answer right now don't you think it's
individualism like every person's
different my dad was a cheat yeah and
but my my brothers I can't say all of
them cheat I can't say all of them don't
you know your hope my sister-in-law's
aren't listening I don't have a single
positive example of a faithful man in my
entire life besides my dad but my dad
was also married like three times before
my mom he's needy yeah but I all all the
males in my family in my Filipino side
are all shitty husband cheaters just
shitty altogether shitty fathers
and for some reason having seen that
really kept me on a straight line when
it comes to relationships I feared I saw
the outcome of all of that and it made
me it struck fear in my heart like I
cannot have that I don't want any part
of that so yeah that's it could go
either way it could it could either make
you say oh kinetically I'm predisposed
to cheating it's just in my family or
you could be the exact opposite of it I
look at comics and I see someone like
Alma I'm gonna be very careful here very
someone like al Madrigal and Kristen you
know they're terrific and monogamy
monogamous have children you have eaten
there it's very nice it's very nice and
they have placemats and you know I mean
like a restaurant and then there are
other comics that I know that they're
married I've never and I've known these
guys for 15 years never met their wives
Yeah right guys very monogamous oh yeah
yeah yeah but I know a couple of guys
that we all know that are loosey-goosey
and I don't I don't you don't condone
and how that does not condone it I say
it I could do that son what are you
doing yeah and they're like hey that's
what we don't like hang out with the
organization like that I just think I
just think that it's you're you're
you're if you lie it's lying and you're
living they put you in that predicament
to like they're yeah they're making you
an accomplice right yes when you're an
accomplice and now you have the
girlfriends crying to you and you're
like oh [ __ ] I can't say anything you
know but I just don't I just don't I
don't condone it but it exists and I
know a lot of guys that do it but I only
know comics you know or actors you know
and um but I know a lot of them that
like look at Van Der Beek he's gotten
his 50th kid with it you know 50 in the
last year home burns Van Der Beek home
birth
[Laughter]
I give Eleanor a round of applause
everybody
she was great guys were great I think
the white guy was the best